[Música]
en China es conocida como el reino de
las plantas y los animales
desde las montañas nevadas de la
frontera con el Tíbet hasta los bosques
tropicales cercanos a mi al mar la
provincia suroccidental alberga una
extraordinaria biodiversidad casi 20.000
especies de plantas y 2000 de animales
una riqueza que apasiona a los
científicos
subimos por encima del 12 la 70 metros
de altura
esta grúa es la más alta del mundo para
observar bosques Gracias a ella Don jin
long lleva 10 años estudiando las copas
de los árboles de guantiansu
literalmente los árboles que miran al
cielo
pueden alcanzar los 80 metros de altura
son gigantes poco conocidos para
estudiar One basta con mirarlo hay que
conocer su microclima y las plantas de
su ecosistema gracias a esta grúa
podemos acercarnos a ellas fácilmente e
incluso tocarlas sin dañarlas
zona de observación una hectárea en la
que se registran casi 7.000 especies de
plantas como estas orquídeas
podemos ver que en one tian shu crecen
muchas orquídeas son orquídeas muy raras
especies en peligro de extinción al
observarlas aquí recogemos datos que
sirven de referencia para protegerlas y
comprender mejor su entorno
desde su grúa el biólogo sigue
llevándose sorpresas todos los días
esta no la conozco nunca hemos
recolectado estas flores y aún no les
hemos puesto nombre
así que vamos a tomar una muestra para
estudiarla y clasificarla
solo el año pasado dunjin Long y sus
colegas descubrieron aquí docenas de
nuevas especies vegetales
las muestras se secan se archivan y se
envían a centros de investigación de
todo el país
es una tarea minuciosa pero esencial
para la protección de las plantas para
preservar la biodiversidad primero hay
que saber qué especies son las más
frágiles en una zona
por ejemplo aquí los son muy escasos por
eso es urgente protegerlas
más del 40% de yunan está cubierto de
bosques pero están amenazados por la
agricultura intensiva sobre todo de
árboles para la producción de caucho la
superficie cultivada casi se ha
triplicado en 30 años
este terreno es una antigua plantación
ahora es una pequeña selva plantada por
la mano de Gerard burgamoísta
durante 20 años este antiguo biólogo
suizo ha transformado pacientemente el
lugar
eso fue en 2003 Cuando llegamos sólo
teníamos árboles de caucho
nos damos ahora tenemos unas 300
especies de árboles sin contar el resto
de la vegetación las plantitas las
florecillas
con el tiempo insectos pájaros y
murciélagos han vuelto aquí todo un
nuevo ecosistema una experiencia de
armonía con la naturaleza que le
gustaría ver reproducida en otros
lugares
confirmó A diferencia de los
monocultivos el bosque tiene capacidad
de adaptación sobre todo al cambio
climático
porque plantar árboles y hacer un
bosquecito muy bonito y todo eso en dos
hectáreas está muy bien pero si
pudiéramos tener un impacto más amplio
por supuesto que sería aún mejor
concienciar sobre la protección del
medio ambiente es la misión de Sí sinon
este fotógrafo de fauna salvaje lleva 40
años capturando la vida salvaje de yunan
tió ese día lleva a los turistas a una
altitud de casi 4.000 metros para
descubrir la fauna local
empecé estos cursos de fotografía de
fauna salvaje en China hace 18 años
con la esperanza de transmitir mi
experiencia y mis conocimientos el mayor
número posible de personas
el señor sí ha influido en muchas
generaciones ha protegió la fauna y la
flora
de la protección animal en la región
todo empezó con esta rara especie los
monos dorados de yunan
estas fotografías los han dado a conocer
y han permitido proteger su hábitat
amenazado durante mucho tiempo por la
deforestación
su población se estima ahora en 3.000
individuos
este grupo vive en una reserva
fácilmente accesible a los turistas
pero para el fotógrafo este espacio
tiene algo de artificial
aquí es fácil observarlos en la vida
cotidiana pero en su entorno natural
en 1992
intenté filmarlos durante tres años
y sólo vi a estos monos dos veces
para proteger la biodiversidad hay que
conocerla
en el parque Botánico de chichombana
esto empieza a una edad muy temprana
esta clase de primer curso ya está muy
avanzada
para sus profesores es crucial que las
nuevas generaciones comprendan la
naturaleza que les rodea la
concienciación y el cambio de
comportamiento son las herramientas más
importantes para proteger la
biodiversidad
por eso estos niños son nuestra máxima
prioridad
la provincia de yunan alberga más de la
mitad de la biodiversidad del país en
solo el 4% del territorio chino